hello you okay how are you I'm good what
about you pretty good how old are you 12
yeah you're 12 yes I am how did you find
this this YouTube stream um on YouTube
just scrolling it just popped up um yeah
like yeah wow that's awesome okay did
you have a question for me or um I'm
Muslim so like I'm just like you know
like also sorry for it cuz like I had
some trouble with like my mic and like
stuff and like oh that was earlier yeah
yeah well welcome back so you you you
you ready to get into this man yeah I
don't discriminate man Jesus was 12
years old when he was in the temple
teaching people so yeah he was he was
like he like he used to debate juw and
like he won every like exactly at the at
12 years old you think you got it like
that yeah yeah that's what that's what I
do I sometimes do and like yeah yeah all
right so yeah what's the question okay
so the question is well let's let's
solidify This Together We believe that
God is all powerful of course right yes
yes I I agree all right beautiful so if
there is something that God can't do or
if he needed help doing it would mean
that he's not all powerful right yeah
okay all right so for some reason it's
gonna be easier talking to Basher than
talking to some of the adults man you
see how easy he answers these questions
goodness gracious why can't the adults
do this all right do you believe that
Allah can have a son if he wanted to
well that's a good question cuz in the
Quran um it says say Allah is wait wait
one sec so yeah in SAS it says that God
has no no no sons and no daughters so
like that's that's kind of a that's a
contradiction cuz like in the Quran it
says that God has no sons and daughters
and like yeah you get me because where
you from I was born in Liverpool the UK
but my mom and dad are from Iraq
nice all
right okay so so Allah doesn't have sons
he has no Sons or
daughters right uh he doesn't have
children it's not a thing that he does
my question is could he though if he
wanted to Cody if he want that's a good
question C if he wanted to well in the
Quran it says that he doesn't so no it
says that he doesn't have have children
does it say does it say that he can't
have children no
right so that's the question could he if
he wanted to well he's God if he wanted
to I mean yeah he would have to or else
he's not God right he would have to be
able to he would have to be able to do
this or else he's not God because he
wouldn't be all powerful make sense yeah
okay so all right so we'll rest on this
that Allah if he wanted to he could have
a son now let me help you out too your
Quran actually does say this in chapter
39:4 it says if Allah willed he to have
a son he could have chosen one from any
of his creation well is it chapter 39
let me see if I get the s name is it
like I'll get the name for you it's uh
zum zumar
aumar I'll put it on the screen right
here so we can see it it's right here oh
hold on right here aumar you see it on
the screen yeah so it says if Allah had
will to choose a son he could have
chosen what he
would have that which he has created be
he glorified he is Allah the one the
absolute so if he wanted to he could
have had a son yeah he could he could
now now here's my next question okay
could Allah have a son by himself or
would he need help to have a son um like
you've been like saying that like he
wait so you've been saying that like go
Allah needs like help from like he need
like a mate to like a wife to like so
wait can you give me that uh can you
show me the the verse where like says
like something wait is it is it a oh
it's in the Quran right let's see
6 101 so it says the originator of the
heavens and the Earth how can he have a
child when there is for him no consort
meaning wife or girlfriend companion
when he created all things and is aware
of all things but can I just read it for
second yeah y the originator of the
heavens and the Earth how can he have a
CH how come he have a child when there
is for him no consort when he created
all wait so you know the the verse where
it says when there is for him no conso
is that like referring to him he needs
like a wife to like or like he needs a
correct correct exactly wait so like
yeah sorry sorry okay no yeah yeah a a
consort is a is it like a wife or
companion wellit so I have a question so
you know how you believe that Jesus
peace be upon Him is God I mean I mean
the Son of God and like yeah like how
was like H like like like how is he like
how is that how is that possible yeah
how is he the Son of God like what what
is like is it like a physical sense or
is it like out
of it's a it's a spir it's not a
physical sense and it's not simply a
term of endearment like it's not
metaphorical he really is the Son of God
uh in a in a very realistic spiritual
way in a spiritual reality so the father
beets the son meaning the son comes from
the Father the very essence of the
father so almost as almost like almost
like how a the sun like out of the Sun
comes light it brings forth light
consistently that's the same way the
father in his within his his Essence
brings forth the son eternally so that's
that's why he's the begotten son of the
father eternally begotten not made all
right so it's not a
physical oh he had to have the father
had to needed a mate and then boom
here's Jesus or anything sexual with
Mary nothing like that he is eternally
begotten of the father he bring he's
coming forth from the father's
Essence so what's the question um so
yeah so the question was with the verse
it says how can Allah have a son when he
has no no consort no wife right so that
shows that he
what what's so according to that verse
it shows that Allah would need a wife in
order to have a son right if you want I
could put the verse back up hold on oh
that's a hard one I know don't don't
feel bad though CU even smart
intelligent grown adults struggle with
this question they can't answer it
because there is no answer do you do you
reckon that she man would answer this
question like get right I would love to
ask uthman this question if I ever get a
chance to see him again he never comes
to the park but I'll definitely ask him
this question for sure but he wouldn't
be able to he'll he'll he'll sound
exactly like how everybody else sounded
on this panel he wouldn't be no
different how can he have a child when
so if he needs a wife to have a child
that means that Allah is dependent on
something else outside of himself wait
so I have a sorry yes so that would mean
that he's not all powerful wait so you
know this you know the Trinity father
son holy spirit is the son is is is the
son is God dependent on the sun there's
a what is it's it's called an
interdependency so like for example the
father is the father because of the son
you can't be a father without the right
so there's that there and then the son
is brought forth from the father's
Essence so there's that there's an
interdependency there now but here's the
difference the difference is that they
are of the same Essence the same being
so they're not depending on something
outside of their own Essence to exist or
do something or be something right
because they're
multi-personality so it's
interdependency they're not depending on
something outside of their divine nature
to be or do something here Allah he's
not a trinity and obviously this mate is
not part of his own Essence either so
for Allah he is dependent on something
outside of his own self outside of his
nature but the father and son they have
the same being Allah he's only you know
he has his being to himself the only one
person and he would need something
outside of him himself outside of his
nature a mate in order to have a son do
that make sense yeah yeah you get it
so so this this would mean that Allah is
not all powerful and therefore is not
God sorry it's Jesus God
if Jesus Is God and God knows everything
then why did Jesus not know the hour
classic man you know you know what we
call what you just did what we call it
the Muslim Shuffle it's when it's it's
immediately like when the Muslim is like
stuck and they can't answer a question
they shift to change the subject you
know question the deity of Christ is if
Jesus Is God why do you know they are if
Jesus Is God you know why you say the
father's great you know they change the
subject it's called the Muslim Shuffle
bro that's so funny and yes you're right
classic Usman
yes my god oh man I'm so happy I stayed
on I was going to close out but I'm glad
I waited for you but do do you see the
problem here I would like the the thing
migi like the oh so he you see the
problem about the the God needs a wife
to God needs okay so yeah you see that
problem you see that the problem it
brings so God is the creator of
everything yes so so God it's okay to
not have an answer bro you don't have to
force it it's okay to say you know what
I don't have an answer to this is okay
if I go on Google and like type the like
and look for an answer yeah yeah so so
uh wait what's the question is it just
just ask put just ask what is the
meaning of Surah 6 what wait what s Sur
6 101 verse 101 s
six first 101 let's see what it says
guys make sure you guys are hitting a
like like button man there better be
well over 2400 likes so you want to look
over that stuff real quick I I can bring
up someone else in the meantime I'm
going to think of my okay so God is the
creator of everything y so so God is all
powerful all knowing supposed to be so
God so God needs a partner to make a son
cuz it's not normal for God to have a
son according to Islam if God is all
powerful and independent
then he doesn't need a partner for
anything he doesn't need anything
outside of himself to do anything
because cu the reason why God needs a
partner is cuz it's in Islam it's like
it's like it's absolutely like it's not
normal for God to have like a son
because
like yeah but even even if he wanted to
if even if he wanted one even if he
wanted to have a son he would need help
that means he's not all powerful so God
is all powerful so he he needs cuz it's
in Islam it's like not normal to have
like for God to have a son so he needs
to create a women and then he does
intercourse right intercourse with the
with his with the wife and well you know
Adam Adam yeah Adam peace be upon him
was made without a father or mother so
and God create and and God in in the
Quran it's it's um Jesus created the the
Messiah Jesus Son of Mary was nothing
but a words of Allah be and he was is
Adam is Adam Allah's son no no no it's
just all right we're not talking about
it's just it's just a Miraculous
Creation right yeah yeah of course so
we're not talking about creation we're
not just talking about Miraculous
Creation I'm talk we're talking about
sunship being a son Allah would need a
mate to have a son right he would need a
mates and mat who created them he would
need to create a a female and have
intercourse with her and then produce a
son so I have a question so in in
Christianity if God wanted to like make
another son did what do you need like a
what do you need like a a wife or could
he just go like be and like he that son
was done that matter of fact we we
are we are sons of God a lot of us oh we
we believe that we're the sons of Adam
and Eve I know that that has nothing to
do with being sons of God though okay
being sons of God we as Christians the
Bible says that we are sons of God once
we come into belief in the Messiah in
Jesus as our Lord and savior we then are
now adopted as sons of God so even God
has more and more Sons through faith and
belief he doesn't need sex to have sons
if Jesus Is God uh where in the Bible
does it state that he's God where in the
Bible does it states sure I already
answered the question that like the
thing like if God he needs to like cuz
it's unnormal for in Islam for God to
have a son so he would he would need to
make a a wife so you can make but but
saying saying that he would need someone
else's help means that he's not God
right yeah but God does God need
anyone's help to do anything no but the
answer is no so since Allah needs help
to do something he's not God you get it
yeah okay yeah in the if if Jesus is God
where in the Bible does it state that
he's God where does he State and I'm GNA
and I'm going to like refuse inshah all
right inshah usually when you say
inshallah it never happens you know as
Muslims you gotta say w I will I will
refuse okay so where in the Bible does
it state that Jesus is God oh I think I
know where you're going with this he's
going to pull up the before Abraham was
born I am no I'm not oh okay okay okay
buddy that's that's a good one though I
like I like that you know that one I'm
just I'm just that's a good one here I
got I got another one for you though are
you gonna put on the screen or yeah yeah
I got you B the originator of the
heavens that's the Quran here it is is
it is he it it's got the English
Standard Version yeah oh okay sorry yeah
waiting for our blessed hope and
appearing of the Glorious God and Jesus
Savior and and SA Jesus Christ but it
doesn't say that Jesus is God it's
saying he's the Savior no it says he's
the great God and savior waiting for our
blessed hope the appearing of the glory
of our great God and Savior Jesus Christ
see but if Jesus Is God wait wait does
it you see how the verse says that Jesus
is God yeah all right so he's God in the
Bible right waiting for our blessed hope
appearing but the Bible is not a
reliable piece of source you didn't ask
me that he asked me to show you in the
Bible where it says he's got waiting for
a blessed hope what version is this what
version is this it's right there English
Standard you want another one English
Standard Version you want another you
want another yeah another version yeah
please all right let's see what we got
let's go go King James wait if Jesus is
God in the Bible say yeah wait one sec
yeah so in the Bible it says God does
not die and Jesus died he died he died
according to his human nature yeah but
he still died yeah as a human his divine
nature doesn't cease so wait what so
when you're talking about Jesus who is
God you're talking about one who took on
a human nature while also keeping and
remaining Divine he is still God while
also adding unto himself a human nature
okay so he's able to experience death
according to his human nature now
there's a difference between what God
does and what God is now what God is
stays the same God is all powerful and
all knowing so not Allah though right
Allah's not all powerful because he
can't he needs help to have a but he
creates a woman and then does
intercourse and then gets a baby no son
so he can't have a son by himself he
needs help he's not all powerful I bet
man would struggle this as well no I
don't man man will fumble this too wait
you know the verse you gave me like yeah
is it is it is it like actual like Surah
no like the like God doesn't need a
thing we'll come to we'll come back to
this later okay yeah yeah it's the
actual store man it's called Al the
cabin let me just here it is again it's
on the screen okay the creator of the
heavens and the Earth how can you okay
I'm just
Al yeah it's an actual verse
Man clay
decrease G what
the what verse what versus it 101 ah 101
got you L an one one one1 the originary
of the heavens and the Earth how could
he have a CH how could he have children
when he has no mates he created all
things and has perfect knowledge of
everything so you're right I know shake
bro of course I'm right he is the
originator of the heavens and earth how
could he have children when he has no
mates no like why would God have
children like why would God have like
children like why why would he have sure
the reason why is because God is love
God is love so okay so it's endearing
and loving for God to not just have
slaves and servants but to consider us
as his children as well that's God sorry
but God is not just one emotion God is a
Rahman the most merciful um you as you
asked
about okay even with being merciful
isn't it merciful to to give let's say
an orphan who has no mother or father
they're an orphan to give this orphan F
uh fatherhood the Bible says that he is
a father to even the orphans he's a
father to the fatherless so the so the
Trinity is the Trinity there CU God is
love and God wants to like the Trinity
the Trinity is there
it's essential because God is love so
like for example here's another reason
why Allah can't be god let's talk about
this love thing God is the greatest
imaginable being right would you agree
yeah I agree I agree and whatever we can
imagine he is the greatest in that
category he's the highest right now
let's let's break it down this way if
God is loving if he's love you believe
you believe Allah has love I believe
that my God has love yeah I do now let
me ask you this is it a great which form
of love is greater loving just yourself
right having your selfish love you take
good care of your own self which or Al
loving yourself but also sharing that
love with another not sharing that love
with another but like God like he like
he is
like yeah but why does he need to love
like why does he need like that's that's
part of his nature that's part of his
nature is not that he needs to love
that's who he is it's what he is he is
love so that's so that's why the Trinity
is there huh yeah you see you see how
you see how so by very nature God Is
Love by very Nature by his core his
Essence God is this is what the Bible
says it says God is love that's what the
Bible says right so for God to be love
that means he is the
greatest imaginable love like whatever
we can think of love to be he's great
he's the greatest so by very nature
since we can imagine a love that's
greater than selfish love but like
shared love shared love is greater than
selfish love which requires two persons
at least then that means that God by his
very core in essence has to at least be
two persons within himself so you know
the try why is it three why can't it be
four well we're breaking this down why
not four so when we're talking about the
forms of love so we already got we got
shared love this is a category of love
we're going to call it shared love when
you share that love with another you
with me so far yeah so wait so you so
when you say the two is it the father
and the son the yeah father son and then
you have also have the Holy Spirit wait
what is the holy spirit like what is it
the very spirit of God spirit is it like
is it like when God becomes a human and
then he like no no it's a very spirit of
God is the he's the he's the he's the
spirit of God he's you know the mind of
God he is you know he's he's God's wind
and power that's who he is and what he
is he guides the Believers he guides the
prophets that's who he is so spirit of
God but hold on you you asked you're
asking a lot of questions which one you
want to answer to so do you want to know
why three and not four or five or six so
no so I'm right so basically okay okay
that do do do you understand why God if
he's God he has to at least be he has to
be
multi-personality personal so so Allah
would have to rely on something outside
of himself to even love the reason why
is because God is so powerful he doesn't
he doesn't need he's the in says he's
the sustainer needed by all meaning
everyone needs him but no one but he
doesn't need anyone okay so who did
Allah love before there was anyone who
did he love no one exactly so he has he
doesn't even have the power to love
within himself there's no no one to love
so he has to wait until he creates
something so that he can love it so that
he can demonstrate love see but my God
by his very core in essence he is love
so he doesn't need creation to
demonstrate that love or for that love
to be evident because within God's
himself he is love so he's not dependent
on creation to love Allah is dependent
on creation again we keep we keep
showing different ways on how Allah
needs help Allah needs help when it
comes to cre to having a son Allah needs
help when it comes to love okay yeah so
is the father and the son coequal wait
don't don't buy pass that pay attention
to this yeah yeah don't okay so no pay
attention to this this is a problem as a
Muslim wait pay attention to what to how
your God needs help he needs creation to
love look man have you ever read the
Bible before no I I I really like all no
but I I want to because like because
like I want to like see the perspective
of Christians and like have debates with
them and like this and that have debates
with them yeah yeah you want to read it
for debates all right no where you can
read it for debates I'll tell you where
to start
get a Bible or use your computer
whatever open up Matthew The Book of
Matthew start there and just read okay
okay all right come back next time can I
just ask one more question no more no
more you already you got a lot to to sit
on I don't want to overload you all
right we literally went through the dawa
script nothing nothing works on that
script you know that right nothing works
all right but have a good night
bro may Allah bless you Happ may the
Lord Jesus bless you h
if Jesus Is God and God knows everything
the mighty Jesus not know the hour oh
yeah so